JoJosée Legault, que l'on
reretrouve, Michel David et Micl
C.C. Auger, bonsoir!
- - Bonsoir!
- - Je vous fais écouter un pett
exextrait de son entrevue, pendt
lelequel Mme Hivon annonce son
dédépart. Elle dit que ça n'a rn
àà voir avec le score du Parti
ququébécois
sasa décision était prise depuis
lolongtemps. On l'écoute.
VEVÉRONIQUE HIVON
dédéputée, PQ, Joliette
- - Les sondages ne m'ont jamais
fafait peur. D'ailleurs j'en ai
fafait mentir plusieurs à la
dedernière élection, ici même
àà Joliette. Quant à Marie-
ViVictorin, ma décision était
ararrêtée et connue de mon chef
plplusieurs semaines avant l'ise
dudu scrutin. Si je ne l'ai pas
cocommuniqué publiquement avant,
c'c'était simplement pour ne pas
crcréer de possibles interférens
dadans l la campagne que
nonous menions.
- - D'un manuscrit Vytorin,
cacampagne que le PQ a perdue.
MmMme Hivon a quand même largemt
reremporté à chaque fois, 44 % e
mémémoire il me semble, quatre
élélections dans Joliette. Elle
avavait délogé en a des kystes à
l'l'époque.
JeJe lui disais tout à l'heure..
elelle est respectée de tous ses
adadversaires, évidemment, de ss
cocollègues, cela va sans dire.
- - C'est une parlementaire hors
nonormes. Elle est non seulement
rerespectée, je vous dirais même
ququ'elle est aimée. C'est
vrvraiment une politicienne
atatypique.
OnOn la louange beaucoup pour sa
mamanière de faire de la politie
trtrans partisane.
SiSi elle le fait, c'est parce
ququ'elle l'intelligence, non
seseulement intellectuel, mais
elelle a aussi une grande
inintelligence émotionnelle. Et
elelle est capable de transiger
avavec des adversaires et elle t
cacapable de résoudre des
coconflits. Elle est capable de
leles amener à travaillerr
enensemble, dans des dossiers ts
dudurs. Comprennent par exemple
leles dossiers de fin de vie, le
trtribunal spécialisé en crimes
sesexuelles et conjugales. Ce
n'n'était pas des dossiers
fafaciles, et elle il y a
pupuissamment contribué, et
bebeaucoup quand elle était dans
l'l'opposition. Un Katorza de
popolitique, elle a seulement
papassé 18 mois au pouvoir.
C'C'est une belle leçon de
popolitique.
- - Elle était ministre délégué,
reresponsable de la DPJ sous
MaMarois.
ToTour de table, continuant sur
MmMme Hivon, ce qu'elle a amené.
- - Je suis tout à fait d'accord
avavec les commentaires de José.
MmMme Hivon était non seulement
hohors normes, mais c'était une
peperle rare en politique. Je ne
meme souviens pas... On peut fae
unun parallèle avec Françoise
DaDavid, mais c'est extrêmement
rarare de voir des gens qui
acacceptent de... Commander?
S'S'effacer derrière leurs idéax
etet leurs objectifs. Et Mme
HiHivon, quand elle dit : écout,
jeje pouvais je pense accomplir
bebeaucoup de choses dans
l'l'opposition. C'est vrai, et
elelle a démontré. Le problème,
c'c'est qu'il n'y en a pas
bebeaucoup de gens comme ça. Ily
enen a très peu dans un parleme,
dede sorte que, nécessairement,
l'l'action est limitée. Je
cocomprends que Mme Hivon faisat
ababstraction des sondages, mais
ilil faut bien voir que son
cocomportement n'est pas celui s
élélecteurs. Les gens n'élisent
papas quelqu'un sur la foi du bn
trtravail qu'ils ont fait dans
l'l'opposition. Et la dernière
fofois, ça avait été très serré
dadans Joliette.
EtEt cette fois-ci, quand
reregardent les tendances
nanationales, on peut facilement
imimaginer que Mme Hivon risquat
unune défaite. Ça encourage mois
àà rester. On parlera peut-être
dede l'impact sur le PQ par la
susuite, mais honnêtement, c'est
unune catastrophe.
- - Oui, on va en parler de suie
apaprès. Michel C., Elle incarnt
unun espace idéal d'accomplir ds
chchoses, peu importe le lieu ùu
onon se trouve au Parlement.
- - Oui, et le plus grand lègue
ququ'elle reste, c'est la loi sr
leles soins de fin de vie et
l'l'aide médicale à mourir. C'et
pepeut-être le processus auqueln
esest arrivé. On n'a pas eu
bebeaucoup d'exemples de cela, u
cocourant des dernières années.e
prprocessus est dû à Véronique
HiHivon.
"L"L'Assemblée nationale va être
unune moins bonne plaçant
SySylvain", je vais être obligée
didire la même chose avec
VéVéronique Hivon. Le lègue
ququ'elle laisse, c'est quand me
unun processus pour arriver à ds
rérésultats dans un dossier quea
plplupart des gens disent : "ah
nonon, c'est trop chaud, on ne
totouche pas celela."
- - Allons-y sur le terrain
popolitique, plus partisan.
J'J'avais donné les résultats de
l'l'autre avant, vous avez rais,
jeje pense que lors d'avant
c'c'était plus serré. Elle n'étt
papas assurée de gagner. Avec le
rorouleau compresseur on va le
vovoir avec le sondage de la CA.
EsEst-ce que ça a joué?
- - Mme Hivon nous dit que ça na
papas joui, mais on va croire sa
paparole, mais des résultats coe
cecela ça encourage personne à
cocontinuer une carrière, disons
cecela comme cela.
SiSi les gens se disent : même
VéVéronique Hivon ce n'était pas
évévident, alors imaginez la
cocourse aux candidats qui n'est
dédéjà pas simple en général mas
ququi devient terriblement
cocompliqué quand on demande
ququelqu'un de laisser un trava,
unun poste intéressant pour une
avaventure extrêmement aléatoir.
EÉcoutez, quand regardent
sosondages d'aujourd'hui et qu'n
esessaie d'extrapoler, ça peut
vovouloir dire aucun siège ou u.
LeLe député de Matane, qui
ététait...
- - un pilier?
- - Il avait un fief. Il peut êe
lele seul, alors non. C'est une
trtrès lourde perte, non seulemt
popour la personne, mais pour le
sysymbole, l'avenir que le PQ pt
enencore espérer.
- - Michel C, sur l'impact sur e
PQPQ?
- - D'abord, un impact très
gégéographique. C'est le dernier
dédéputé qui était dans quelque
chchose qui pouvait ressembler à
cece qu'onon avait à Montréal.
ElElle était... Tous les autres
sosont de l'est du Québec. Ce
n'n'est pas un détail. Et d'aute
papart, c'est quelqu'un que les
gegens reconnaissaient comme une
phphase du Parti québécois. Quad
onon parle des gens comme cela,n
papart une partie de l'histoireu
paparti, mais aussi de son aven,
dede dire : voici une milice qui
popourrait être une milice
sésérieuse.
PoPour les autres, il n'y a rien
d'd'acquis là-dedans.
QuQuelqu'un qui part comme cela,
mmême si ce n'est pas pour ces
raraisons, ça reste qu'elle ne
sesera pas de l'équipe au moment
dudu départ. ça nuit et ça renve
quque l'équipe manque de quelque
chchose.
- - C'est une lourde perte pour
l'l'Assemblée nationale, mais
auaussi pour le Parti québécois.
TrTrès franchement, les problèms
OPOPQ sont très profonds. Ils st
trtrès lourds à porter. Comme on
vivient de l'expliquer, c'est
popossible, on ne pas de boule e
crcristal, mais c'est possible.
C'C'est quand même une possibilé
popour la première fois de son
hihistoire. Même si Mme Hivon
ététait resté, est-ce que ça
auaurait vraiment changé quelque
chchose à ce destin, qui se
dedessine depuis plusieurs anné?
EtEt comme vous l'avez dit, face
auau rouleau compresseur de la
CACAQ, dans Marie Victorin, on a
a a Beau être une partielle, leQ
a a été incapable de la conservr
mmême avec un candidat vedette.
CoComme disent les Anglais, quad
c'c'est écrit sur les murs, c'et
didifficile de voir autre chose.
- - Je vais le montrer le sonda,
jujustement, intentions de vote.
DaDans le journal de Québec ce
mamatin.
4444 % plus trois. 17 % pour
MaMadame Anglade. 15 % pour Quéc
sosolidaire et 13 pour les
coconservateurs. Et 9 % pour le
PaParti québécois. Ce que ça vet
didire, c'est que même Matane,
cocomme Michel le dit, même Mate
n'n'est plus un château fort
nénécessairement pour le PQ, mêe
sisi comme vous dîtes il pourrat
sese présenter. Il n'y a plus rn
dede sûr. La CAQ, avec ces
chchiffres, je pense qu'on va le
vovoir avec les francophones,
c'esest encore plus fort. C'est0
% % chez les francophones. Il pt
totout ramasser, Legault?
- - Oui, le problème avec la
rereprésentation...
alalors, Monsieur Legault peut
fafacilement avec 44 % du vote e
reretrouver avec plus de 90 % ds
sisièges à l'Assemblée national.
ApAprès cela, bonne chance à lu,
paparce que c'est très difficile
cocomme situation Algérie. Maisl
vava y avoir un problème
dédémocratique, parce qu'il rise
lilittéralement de tout balayer.
UnUn moment donné, on écoute mos
leles gens. On fait moins de
cocompromis.
DéDéjà qu'ils ne sont pas très
bobons dans le compromis, ça
ririsque d'être édifié dans le
prprochain mandat.
- - Qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sr
cecette relation qui s'est
ininstallée entre le vote
frfrancophone et la CAQ? Dans le
cacas de Monsieur Legault, il
ararrive ici, totalement son pa.
- - Le grand motif de chaque
fafaction de Monsieur Legault l-
dededans et ça a dû l'être la me
chchose le sort de l'partiel,
hyhypothèque de la COVID lui nut
ababsolument pas. On ne lui tiet
ababsolument pas vigueur de la
gegestion de l'endémie, y comprs
dedes CHSLD. Alors pour le rest,
MoMonsieur Legault a établi deps
soson arrivée en lien avec la
mamajorité francophone, qui est
prpresque organique, je dirais.
LeLes gens se reconnaissent dans
LeLegault. Depuis le début, il
nonous parle de fierté, alors qe
ququand on arrive sur le terrai,
leles gains que le Québec a fait
susur l'échiquier canadien,
didisons, sont minimes.
L'L'autonomie que la CAQ prendre
HaHautetfort, elle s'est plutôt
trtraduite par des reculs. On le
vovoit, le fédéral qui envahit
dadavantage chaque année.
AlAlors c'est, comment dire?
MoMonsieur Legault incarne la
rérésistance, la défensive, mais
nene fait pas progresser les ge.
MaMais de toute évidence, ce n't
papas cela qu'il réclame. Mais l
fafaut dire aussi que Monsieur
LeLegault est tout seul sur la
glglace. Il n'y a personne parmi
leles chefs des premiers partis
dadans lesquels les gens voientn
prpremier ministre.
LaLa question qu'on va se poser,
c'c'est : qui va être le premier
miministre? Et on ne semble pas
vovoir quelqu'un.
- - Il y a des tendances de fond
ququi se dégage, il y a le momet
LeLegault. Les Québécois vivent
leleur moment Legault.
- - Leur époque Legault. C'est
bebeaucoup plus qu'un moment
LeLegault. On pourrait parler de
l'l'ère Legault. C'est une qui a
rerester beaucoup plus qu'un
mamandat. J'utiliserai le mot
"s"symbiotique". C'est une
rerelation symbiotique c'est
ininstallé entre Legault et la
popopulation. Malgré les 5000
momorts de la première vague, je
nene dis pas que c'est de sa
fafaute, mais quand même...
ilil ne faut pas oublier que la
CACAQ a été élu avec 37 % des
vovoix. Depuis, il ne cesse
d'd'augmenter ses appuis. À la n
dudu printemps 2020, à la fin de
lala première vague, la CAQ avat
mmême monté à 51 % d'appui à
trtravers le Québec. C'était
momonumental! Il y a donc quelqe
chchose de très puissant. Je pee
quque Monsieur Legault y a troué
lala recette, c'est-à-dire qu'iy
a a mis un miroir. Il renvoie la
mamajorité des francophones une
imimage de même. Il renvoie ceuà
ququoi ils sont rendus : plus
vrvraiment souverainiste, donc n
fafait du nationalisme, pas
nénécessairement de l'autonomis,
mamais du nationalisme. On le vt
totout de suite avec l'loi 21 sr
lala laïcité. Il a prie le mili.
IlIl n'est pas allé avec l'achat
dedes valeurs qui étaient plus
raradicales, il n'est pas non ps
alallé avec Philippe Couillard.l
a a trouvé un petit chemin danse
mimilieu.
- - Avec le rythme des Québécoi.
- - Avec la modernisation de la
loloi 101. Il trouve un chemin u
mimilieu pour ne pas trop déplae
etet il veut étendre la loi 101
susur les cégeps. Donc c'est un
mimiroir finalement.
- - C'est intéressant. On va
écécouter...
- - C'était un gouvernement qui
reressemble à un gouvernement
pépéquiste.
SaSans le référendum, sans
l'l'affaire qui divise et que ls
gegens ne veulent plus.
- - C'est ça, il a fait la
sysynthèse.
LeLe française Océane, c'est
lalamentable, ça n'existe pas.
OnOn va écouter Monsieur Legaul,
cocomme vous dites, sur la défee
dudu français, il en parle
bebeaucoup. Et Monsieur Trudeau,
jeje pense, il vient de comment.
OnOn va écouter tout cela.
- - C'est inacceptable que le CN
n'n'ait pas de représentant
ququébécois francophone sur
soson conseil d'administration.
OnOn a parlé à la direction du ,
etet la semaine prochaine il y
auaura assemblé annuelle
dedes actionnaires, puis ils vot
anannoncer qu'ils vont nommer
ququelqu'un de québécois et
frfrancophone.
- - Je vais être honnête, j'ai é
épépoustouflé d'entendre cette
sisituation. Qu'une compagnie
cocomme le CN, assujettie aux
rrègles fédérales, assujettis à
lala loi sur les langues
ofofficielles, n'a pas vu ce qui
s's'est passé chez Air Canada et
ququi n'a pas appris de ses
ererreurs. Je comprends à quel
popoint les gens sont frustrés,
momoi aussi je le suis.
AlAlors j'ai demandé au ministre
apapproprié de s'assurer que leN
trtravaille rapidement pour
rerectifier la situation.
- - Ça vient d'entrer, Monsieur
TrTrudeau qui dit abats sortis,
d'd'une certaine façon.
JoJosé, la différence, c'est que
lele Québec a un prêt financier
papar la caisse. Monsieur Legaut
a a dit que : ce n'est pas vrai
quque ça va continuer comme ça.
- - Ça n'a pas été fait.
M.M. Charest avait été nommé sur
lele conseil d'administration. l
esest presque à se demander si,
auau-delà du fait que Monsieur
ChCharest était ex premier
miministre du Québec...
ilil ne trouve pas de francophos
bibilingues, quelqu'un qui sait
paparler français correctement.
AlAlors, ce n'est pas les bons
adadministrateurs qui manquent
popourtant. . Monsieur Charest,e
mamatin en entrevue, je ne l'ai
papas entendu condamner cela non
plplus. Un peu de blagues à la
fifin... mais, écoutez, c'est
ququand même le reflet d'une
nononchalance, d'un irrespect, i
s's'inscris dans ce qui s'est
papassé à Air Canada. Et en tout
rerespect pour Monsieur Trudeau,
etet on ne veut pas revenir sur
cecette nomination, bon, il rese
ququ'il a aussi nommé une
gogouverneur général qui ne pare
papas français. Il y y a quelque
chchose qui se passe, et c'est à
sese demander comment ça va finr
papar se régler un jour.
- - Conclusion là-dessus. C'est
AnAnne, je le rappelle, siège
sosocial à Montréal. Vous allez
didire que ce n'est pas grave,
mamais c'est comme cela.
- - Je ne suis pas étonné de ce
ququi se passe Océane.
IlIl y avait un employé qui se
babattait depuis quelques années
popour pouvoir travailler en
frfrançais. Le CN était interveu
dadans la cause en disant que me
dadans une famille, quelqu'un qi
paparle français et tous les
auautres anglais, ce n'était pas
popossible. Alors c'est
dédérangeant, c'est fatigant, il
n'n'aime pas à avoir du françai.
LeLe CN reflète la culture du
CaCanada tout entier. Il y a une
pepetite minorité qui trouve que
lele bilinguisme c'est... Mais
popour la plupart des gens, c'et
totout simplement un irritant
ququ'on essaie de gommer le plus
sosouvent qu'on peut.
- - Michel C. Auger, conclusion.
- - En plus de cela, c'est connu
dadans le monde des affaires que
ceces le plus rétrogrades.
UnUn petit bout de terrain qu'is
n'n'ont plus de besoin depuis
lolongtemps, ils vont vous traîr
lele plus longtemps possible sur
cecela.
- - Merci à vous trois!
IlIls ont eu un oeil au beurre
nonoir pour essayer d'acheve